in Teresa so it was a mouthful I'm going
to talk about a perfect for lodging a
mixture deconvolution problem and how we
can apply this problem to cancer
sequencing data so just quickly want to
start by reviewing some of the things
we've seen earlier this week so a tumor
is a mixture of heterogeneous cells that
have different compliments of mutations
and if you were to sequence each of this
these cells individually and also assume
that are no copy number aberrations then
we can represent our input as a matrix a
binary matrix M the rows of this matrix
correspond to individual tumor cells and
the columns correspond to snv's and our
two states so state 0 corresponds to a
non mutation the normal state and state
1 corresponds to a point mutation and if
you make a second assumption about the
evolution of this tumor so if you assume
that a point mutation only happens once
try the entire evolution of a tumor then
this binary matrix admits the perfect
for large new tree and we can find this
perfect for large entry in linear time
following the result by Dan gosfield
however most sequencing data is not
single cell sequencing it's actually
obtained using book sequencing and with
book sequencing our samples correspond
to mixtures of tumor cells in unknown
proportions and in fact our measurements
are very frequencies which are the
fraction of reads that have the variant
allele and we can represent our input
again as a matrix this time it's not a
binary matrix but it's a matrix with
values between zero and one the rows
correspond to sample so we have three
samples here and the columns correspond
through snv's and each entry is the
variant allele frequency of that as
entry in a specific sample now given
these variant allele frequencies we
still want to find a tree but at the
same time we also want to find out the
composition of every sample so more
precisely we want to know the proportion
of the clones that occur in a sample and
this is the this is basically a
two-state perfect Falacci make sure the
conclusion problem let's be studied
extensively we've seen a lot of talk
this week's this week and in our recent
ice and beef paper we basically took a
step back and we looked at the
underlying cognitive oriole problem that
assuming error-free data and we've shown
at this problem that the decision
problem is np-complete so in our work we
assume there are no copy number
aberrations and today I want to talk
about copy number aberrations so one way
of dealing with copy number aberrations
if by trying to move everything into
state won the mutated state so what you
could do is you could try to rescale you
variant allele frequencies such that
they correspond to the fraction of tumor
cells that have a mutation and one way
of doing this is by looking at purity
and ploidy and in fact this has been
done a lot however if you want to model
copy number aberrations as events of
your tree then you have to consider more
than two states in your tree so you have
to look at a multi-state phylogeny model
and that's going to be the topic of this
talk so what i will do is i will give
you a formal problem statement that
catches this problem i will show you
what solutions for this problem look
like
and I will briefly touch upon how we
apply this this model doing for
phylogenetic tree that model the
interplay between s and visa series so
let's solve the problem statement so I
will introduce this by basically having
an analogue between the two state case
and the multiset k so in a two-state
case so this was our eyes and be work
input we're giving this frequency matrix
and what we want to do is like a set we
want to infer a perfect for large new
tree and we also want to infer mixing
proportions so this perfect Falacci tree
can be modeled by a binary matrix and
the next in proportions that I have over
here so for instance if you look at a
third sample and let's look at the red
mutation so that corresponds to the
third sample there so it's the third
column that's it has a frequency of
point six and that's simply the sum of
these two proportions so what we want to
do is given this frequency matrix we
want to find a tree and mix in
proportions such that they are
compatible with our observed input
measurements and the mixing proportions
can be captured by a matrix that we call
the usage matrix and the entries have to
be non-negative and they have to sum up
to it most one so one way of looking at
this problem is basically looking at it
as a matrix factorization problem so
we're given this frequency matrix and we
want to factorize it into two matrices a
perfect for large any matrix and they
use its matrix and well that's basically
what I've shown over here so that's the
variant allele frequency factorization
problem now let's look at the
multi-state case so in the military
state case the infinite sites assumption
that we've made over here translates to
the Infinity Lewis assumption and
basically a character can have more than
one state in fact the characters k
states state 0 is the initial state so
that's the same thing and you're only
allowed to change to the same state once
so that's the multi-state case and to
make a contrast instead of having one
matrix in
boot we have a frequency dancer as input
so what so basically we have an
additional dimension which corresponds
to the states and if you take slices of
this frequency tensor we basically get
three matrices over here corresponding
to the three states columns correspond
to characters and rows correspond to
samples and the goal is to find this
milky state perfect for lodging tree so
that's still the same thing we will find
a perfect for logic tree and we can
capture this tree as three separate
binary matrices and in fact what we want
to do is we want to find the usage
matrix and its uses matrix has to be
applied to every frequency slice so
instead of solving one matrix
factorization problem we have to solve k
matrix factorization problems where the
matrix u is shared across all slices so
this is the perfect for lodging you make
sure the co-evolution problem and this
is a paper that's going to be presented
let's recon this year kids states
correspond in terms of people yeah I
will come back to that later but just to
let me just quickly go back to my
introduction so what I'm trying to do is
I'm trying to capture copy number
aberrations to separate states so they
so basically just the case statesville
and go different combinations of
maternal copies paternal copies and the
number of mutations that you have the
copy number right it's it's the
interaction of a copy number aberrations
and an sm v so you look at one specific
locus and you want to know how many
maternal copy share how many paternal
copies you have and how many of those
copies have to ask me but i will come to
that later it's not where the assemblies
occur you're not good distinguishing one
copy from the other you're just counting
that's it first day I'm not
yes let's let's see if we can actually
talk about it later so
so let me tell you what solutions of
this problem look like so again I will
go back to the two-state case and in the
two-state case we have the infinite size
assumption and because of the infinite
size assumption a character change
instead only once meaning that once you
get a mutation you will keep having that
mutation so there's no back mutations
and that something really cool happens
so if you look at this tree over here so
in this node a mutation one foo courtesy
was introduced so that's the first time
it happened and because of this infinite
size assumption everything in the sub
tree rooted at it snowed will have state
14 courtesy and what you're in fact have
is that a subtree of the vertices that
I've state 14 character see is the same
as the sub tree rooted at the vertex
that first introduced statement for
courtesy so that's a crucial observation
so these two subtrees are the same and
what you could what you effect we do is
you could actually think about your
frequencies as a mass of a sub tree
rooted at this vertex so the frequency
of characters see with state one is
simply the sum of the usages of all the
vertices in that sub tree so if you want
to have the usage of this single node
you could simply take the frequency of
this entire subtree the blue one and
subtract the green frequency and the
orange frequency and like I said this
has to be non-negative and this
corresponds to the some condition and
this is a necessary and sufficient
condition two solutions for the problem
now let's go to the melody staircase so
here we have the infinite alleles
assumption so we have more than one
state and now something different
happens so if I look at at the same
character so state 14 character c so
this sub tree rooted at this vertex
conveys three vertices but here this
this vertex over here we introduce a new
state for character c so the sub tree
rooted at this vertex has three virgin
and a sub tree where character CS state
one just as two vertices so that's
that's basically different so we no
longer capture the mass or the sum of
the usages of the subtree rooted vertex
and if you want to do that we have to
look at the Senate sets so if i look at
this vertex over here i see that i have
a descendants state too and by
incorporating those i can still arrive
at the sub tree rooted at this vertex as
the disjoint union of in this case the
the yellow and the purple subtree
so by doing this I can apply the same
trick to basically obtain a condition on
having non negative usages by requiring
that a cumulative frequency and this
give me the frequencies defined using
the descendant sets is at least the sum
of the cumulative frequencies of the
children so that's the multi-state some
condition it's a generalization and to
see why this is a generalization you
could think about the K equals 2 case
and you k equals 2 case every descendant
set it's a singleton it has only state 1
so basically this equation becomes the
same as this equation okay so how do we
find a solutions that satisfy the some
condition so in a two-state case one way
of doing this is by basically defining a
graph a simple directed graph where the
vertices correspond to mutations or
snv's and there is an edge between two
mutations if the frequency of the parent
is at least the frequency of the child
and then what you want to find our
spanning trees in this graph that
satisfy the some conditioner you just
spoke about and that's in fact all that
you need to do and finding such a
constraint spending 33 is guys well
deciding whether is such a 3 exists NP
complete and in our ISO be work we've
shown in our reduction that's what we've
given a reduction that where the number
of samples is linear in the number of
characters now let's go to the
multi-state case so here the situation
is more complicated so instead of a
simple graph we have a multi graph with
no the edges at the nodes correspond to
character state pairs and the edges the
multi edges are labeled by valid
descended set pairs so we have to keep
track of the Senate sets which we don't
know a priori so we look at all possible
descended sets and we only look at valid
the Senate set bears and in fact we
still want to do the same thing so we
want to find a spanning tree that
satisfies this generalized some
condition the multi-state some condition
and in our new work we strengthen this
result so we've basically shown that the
the problem is np-complete 42 states so
that's the same as here but the number
of samples is just too so it's not fixed
parameter tractable in the number of
samples which is actually useful
parameter you have but unfortunately
that's not the case so how do we apply
this to cancer sequencing so let me see
if I can answer your question now so our
input our read that phrase shows the
allele frequencies and variant allele
frequencies and the characters that we
want to have correspond to s and V so we
look at snv's and for every smv we model
the state as a Triple X Y Z X is the
number of maternal copies why is the
number of paternal copies as he is the
number of mutations that you have for
that locus so the normal state
corresponds to 110 and what we do also
is we assume podesta characters so we
assume that we know the ordering of the
states so basically we assume that we
have an ordering of the state and then
given a state tree basically we fix the
order of the state then we try to infer
by the character the very low frequency
that we observe and the reader pressures
in the building frequencies are
compatible with one another we enumerate
all such possibilities and by doing so
we can infer phylogenetic trees where we
capture the interplay between snv's and
seemingly so we basically try to do that
simultaneously so over here we have a
smv on this gene where that first
underwent a single copy deletion and
then it gained the mutation so to
conclude
I've shown you how the infinite sites
model for SUVs can be generalized to the
affinia Toulouse model for smbs and
cna's I've introduced the perfect
phylogeny makes deconvolution problem I
briefly shown you what solutions of this
promo look like I said something about
the hardness and I've shown you how this
can be applied to cancer secrecy and
data and there are more applications to
this problem so this is really important
to make sure deconvolution problem so
with that I'd like to conclude by
thanking been my advisor and by my cough
that's great on Layla and rest of their
FL research group and I skipped over a
lot of details but there will be a
preprint available soon on the archive
thanks Nick questions so the bottom line
in every single copy number love you
cannot distinguish okay which is low
frequency with my copy number versus a
club with low copy number and a high
high frequency so you must have an upper
bound you must have some kind of an
assumption to favor one yes so okay let
me give you a little bit more detail so
what I assume as an input are basically
out so first you need to run a copy
number color and for every smv it's
going to tell you what a copy number
state is and it's actually going to be
phased into x and y and will tell you
the proportions of those so that's the
input that we take and then you really
want to have it anyway little flow you
need to start somewhere and then we
basically well there's still a lot of
combinations and this is where multiple
states how multiple samples helped a lot
because they can rule out certain
combinations and that's what we see
happening in our experiments on real
data
so how do you handle errors I suppose
you're there yeah great question so I
skipped over that completely so what we
do is um we basically generalized our
input instead of being a point for a
character in a sample in a specific
state we basically have a confidence
interval and then the problem is to find
a spanning tree and at the same time I
also solve a flow problem we want to
assign frequencies within the respective
intervals such that you satisfy the
multi-state some condition so that's how
we try to capture errors that's fishing
from Russell right okay at the same
question okay so it's nice to speaker